the Joe Rogan experience are you from
military background my dad you know my
dad was so that's what my parents met my
dad was stationed in Germany
my mom was fleeing Thailand um to hurt
her first husband was like physically
abusive to her so she was leaving
Thailand and she came to Germany to find
her a GI and then found my dad she came
to find a GI specifically well you know
I think she was coming to get away but
right now is she wanted to she wanted a
better life for her at the time and my
dad was in the hospital and so my mom
was taking care of him food and made him
fall in love there you go
and my dad always jokes he says he tells
us a story all the time he's like yeah
your mom was taking care of me and then
she told me that you're pregnant and
then twelve months later you were born
oh that's funny but no they fell in love
it was just a really long pregnancy just
weird just kind of weird I don't know
why but I was small but no yeah and then
so then we moved to Colorado and I was
born when we lived in Germany for a
little bit when I was younger and then
back to Colorado and I grew up in Aurora
Colorado oh cool when did you start
training Oh probably around ten yeah
yeah around ten I have a older brother
he's four years older than me he's my
half-brother and I really wanted to do
gymnastics as a kid and my parents just
we just couldn't afford it was really
expensive and so my brother found a
little karate spot at the church just
across the street and it was the
community like a community karate thing
and so it was something that all three
of us could do and so yeah we jumped
into it and I fell in love with it I
just it just took over my life and
changed changed my life did you start
competing really quickly yeah I think so
and I first it's funny because at first
so I would do like the the karate
tournaments and so there's point
sparring and then there's the Coty's
I thought the Coty's were silly and I
remember going in and doing points
firing and getting knocked on my butt
and I was like okay I think I want to do
some Coty's then I want to bring some
trophies home but so yeah I competed
karate from 10 all the way up until I
was 18 and so I did a lot of like the
flashy like extreme martial arts Coty's
with the like the flips and stuff like
that but I always I always came back to
sparring because I wasn't good at it mmm
I was like it bugged me it bugged me
that I that I wasn't good at it and then
I found my niche because it's points
boring so you get to two points to the
head for kicks to the head so I would
just sit back and let him come in and
just kick him in the head a couple times
and win the fight so how did you go from
that did you go from that to kickboxing
or did you go right into MMA like when
did you when did you just start training
him a man so so I did I did karate and
then I got my black belt in karate
what Chi America freestyle and then so I
think around 18 or 19 I was kind of just
exploring doing a couple different
things so I did wushu for a couple of
years and I competed in wushu and then I
did a little bit of kemple and and then
kind of dabbled a little bit into
kickboxing and so it all kind of just
happened pretty strangely I was in
college I was working at Hooters and I
was doing that all these like little
side jobs like doing photo shoots for
this and that and I was a ring girl for
MMA shell I had never seen MMA and I
remember just walking around the cage
and thinking man I want to be like on
the inside I said that one that looks
cool I think I could do it cuz it was
mixed martial arts you know and I
remember talking to a promoter and he
kind of laughed me off and it was just
like whatever you know you're a ring
girl and it was a smaller local show
Donald Cerrone was actually fighting
that show and he heard me yeah and so he
came to my work at Hooters and I wasn't
there and he was just like left me no
serious about fighting get your ass in
the gym Wow where was this is in
Colorado in the night so I went to go
train and went to go training with
McDonald and you know we we Jim hopped
from place to place I trained with with
Dwayne I trained with Trevor I trained
with what with all the guys and and so I
took a couple smokers would drive you
know drive around the region and took a
couple smokers and then it was like at
that point when I was still in college
and I just was not happy in college I I
was kind of wandering around aimlessly
is really successful in high school and
you know I it just didn't transfer over
to college I still I got good grades I
was 3.8 you know I was going to do you
but I wasn't happy I just I there was
something missing and it was it was the
martial arts this is a big part of my
life and you needed a real challenge
need something physical to probably
right I would imagine that someone
growing up doing martial arts as long as
you did you like the thrill of using
your body and moving around it's like
that it's so important like once once
you do that and you compete and it
becomes a part of you the idea of like
sitting in a classroom all day and then
eventually sitting in a job all day was
probably not not that compelling yeah I
think so I think that um I just school
for I was going to school so I was
double majoring in theater and sports
science mmm so I was majoring in theater
because I got a scholarship for it and I
was doing sports science I wanted to be
like physical therapist for like a
sports team or something like that or
even a martial arts team but yeah so I
decided to take a like a little bit like
a break from that and my mom my grandma
was sick in Thailand so then I was like
I told my mom I just got with her for
the summer and I went to visit my
grandma in Thailand and all I was out
there I I went to sit at home more Thai
camp and
absolutely fell in love with it they
made fun of me because of my my karate
kicks yeah it's interesting how
different karate kicks are yeah tied
kicks
yeah and they were looking at me like I
was crazy but like what no I'm a black
belt I know what I'm doing they're
laughing at me we're training on
concrete outside these little
five-year-old kids are doing ten year
old ten minute rounds and my feet are
blistering up from kicking over and over
and over on the concrete but I loved it
I fell in love with it it kicked my butt
and I fell in love with it and I came
back and I dropped out of college and I
decided to pursue fighting Wow
so where did you learn grappling so so
my first MMA fight was kind of just it
was supposed to be an amateur fight and
like I said it was training with
McDonald and he was training at a school
in Vail and so I would I would go to I
would I would work on the weekends and
then drive up to Vail and train my
grappling and all of it like that like
all of the MMA and so so you basically
trained MMA together like you didn't
take specific grappling classes but
would imagine that that was the thing
that you needed to concentrate on the
most right mm-hmm
yeah and I figured okay is my protein or
it was supposed to be amateur but the
girl that are supposed to fight fell
through and the only girl that they had
available was already Pro she was like -
no pro and of course you know how Donald
is he's like whatever [ __ ] it so that's
a good double backside so I was like all
right I mean we've been training so I
literally had four weeks in Miami in my
like throughout my my karate career we
would have grappling nights when we
would do grappling but it wasn't
anything like substantial so yeah four
weeks of grappling training and I
figured okay you know I'll just use my
stand-up to win the fight and she was
swinging from from way back here and
trying to take my head off so I ended up
taking her down I take her down like six
or seven times I'm been winning the
fight by taking her down and
ground-pounding that's crazy
yeah did you say while you were doing it
like wow this is so weird that I'm doing
this it was I I wasn't thinking at all I
was just in the moment having the time
of my life what were you thinking that
this was what you're gonna wind up doing
like professionally are you just
thinking I can't believe I'm doing this
oh yeah that's exactly I was like this
is so much fun it was that the
Broomfield events are not I don't know
if that's that's still called the
Broomfield event Center in Colorado but
yeah I think a bank owns it now yeah
those changed names there's so much fun
but never in my life I thought I would
be a top UFC contender never and on your
way your goal is to be the first mommy
yeah to ever win a title yeah that's
possible 100% you're in them you're in
the hunt right now like what are you
ranked I'm ranked 7 mm-hmm 7th but I
don't think the rankings are anything
they're weird and they're weird yeah
it's like sometimes someone will beat
somebody and then that person still
ahead up in the ranking I'm like explain
that I just I don't understand the
rankings though I feel like I've won my
last two fights and I've gone down in
rankings all right you wanna hasn't
fought and she's gone down in rankings
and some of the girls haven't fought and
they've gone up in rankings I just think
the rankings are crazy
[Applause]